tueurs à gages
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un garçon il avait 15 ans 15 16 ans
J'avais un petit garçon vers qui je sautais
États-Unis et l'a attaqué avec des balles
ils ont jeté le travail de la
mais ils l'ont fait parce qu'il était sur le côté
mexicain
ce qu'ils cachent derrière tout le temps c'est
qu'ils les auraient agressés
pierres mais
C'est déjà inhumain, eh bien, une personne
ne plus prendre sa vie juste parce que
tu veux quoi sinon plus pour vouloir traverser
aux États Unis
[Musique]
C'est l'entrepôt où ils sont allés
criblé de 58 hommes et 14 femmes
immigrés sans papiers essayant d'atteindre
Déclare les citoyens du Honduras
Le Brésil, El Salvador et l'Équateur étaient
intercepté par des membres du
organisation criminelle connue sous le nom de
carrelage
[Musique]
s'élève d'un côté de l'est
Augmenter
[Musique]
beauté
Ravi de vous rencontrer. Comment vous appelez-vous?
Je viens du Mexique sous le sud du sud
et tu seras nodal oui
voyons ce qui se passe à Nogales
C'est bien, ni moi ni mes amis
sébastien beaucoup
Vous venez également du Mexique Honduras
Honduras
il fait chaud il fait chaud
Vous n'avez donc pas de passeport ?
tu dois te cacher et tout de tout le monde
Et qu'as-tu laissé à la famille
frères et sœurs
pour eux nous nous battons sur ce chemin
avec foi en Dieu que nous allons faire quelque chose
et si ce n'est pas le cas, nous y retournons et
Où as-tu dormi
prendre le train et monter à Nogales
nous gardons tous ensemble
ne te détache pas de là-haut si tu
tu arrives à bien glisser ne lâche pas
des drames peuvent arriver
donc avec tes bras tu dois courir
plus avec le train run run run
l'équilibre
[Musique]
là ils montent
L'autre
[Musique]
c'est encore le plan
pour ça
ainsi que ça ira oui tu peux vite
bien s'il l'attrape et te grimpe
Je ne vais jamais le rattraper à cette vitesse
presque la plupart doivent partir
courir à la partie
exprès. Alors il le fait parce que
ils sont ici
ok excuse moi alors
de nourriture par ici pour les maisons
ok nous serons merci
[Musique]
oh qu'est-ce qui t'est arrivé
est avec une couchette avant
qui a séparé le train ici à la gare et
Arrivé ici je suis allé à l'hôpital
Oh bien sûr ils t'ont cuisiné quand c'était hier
Dimanche
et tu essaies d'aller vers le nord jusqu'à
noyers
salut bien
[Musique]
Le père Enrique est ici
nous te remercions seigneur pour ces
nourriture que vous nous avez fourni
Nous vous demandons également pour les personnes qui
Ils les ont faites, demandons pour tout le monde
nos marchandises
donne du pain seigneur à ceux qui ont faim
et faim soif de justice pour nous qui
nous avons du pain par le Christ notre Seigneur
au nom du père du fils du
Saint Esprit
[Musique]
cette première première partie peut
recevoir un ou plusieurs pas encore plusieurs
fois
et ils le font ils le font beaucoup ils mangent beaucoup
tu lui as dit exactement que parfois
les migrants nous ont emmenés ils nous ont séparés
beaucoup peuvent être petits
ne vient plus
ce qui se passe, c'est la politique n'est pas
laisser le train monter pour qu'ils n'avancent pas
mais l'état de l'état est présenté
mexicain
[Musique]
ou la police loin de les cuisiner
Eh bien, prenez soin d'eux, que se passe-t-il?
profitant souvent de la puissance
Eh bien, plusieurs fois ils le tiennent
que peut-il arriver aux migrants de
quand ils viennent du sud jusqu'à ce qu'ils partent
au nord
adversités et si l'adversité est
ça va attraper le train le pire c'est
depuis qu'il a frappé depuis qu'il s'est fait cambrioler
puisqu'ils les ont extorqués depuis bien
vos biens vous sont volés ou pris
[Musique]
maintenant tu sais que tu dois arriver en retard
[des rires]
La vérité
marchons
[Musique]
d'où d'où ont-ils parlé
écoute ils me disent que depuis
L'Amérique centrale parle de ce père et
moi dans tout le Mexique
le père et c'est pourquoi nous savons qu'ici
c'était bien, tout le monde s'en souvient maintenant
quand ils reviennent
[Musique]
Eh bien, j'ai apporté de l'eau pour le train de la banane
fromage fromage vitamines
et les pommes ok
[Musique]
eau de fruits
dans la tradition c'est moche pour beaucoup
rien n'arrive à beaucoup de gens
quelque chose arrive aux gens ici mais à beaucoup
Des choses laides arrivent aux gens, hein ?
former le train rien ne se passe
trois fois moins je me suis évanoui et quand
Ils m'ont réveillé parce que je ne pouvais pas le supporter
les coups de pied dans les côtes qui
ils m'ont donné et m'ont réveillé à nouveau
Je ne sais pas qui serait ce problème ici non
Je sais qui ce serait
ou ils s'habillent en noir tous avec un chapeau
a également couvert le pistolet facial et tout
Alors ils m'ont laissé, regarde, je ne pouvais pas voir
Je parce que les yeux juste avec ça
tu peux regarder un peu l'oreille
C'était comme ça gros et je l'apporte
battue ici je la ramène fracturée
Ils m'ont battu machin mais au moins ils ne l'ont pas fait
ils ont tué le patron parce qu'ils m'ont jeté
ils ont dit regarde ce qu'ils me disent regarde maintenant
oui c'est dit pour d'autre argent et ils m'ont jeté
C'est comme ça que j'ai expliqué le bon Non pour
s'il te plait ne m'écoute pas
Sebastián, qui était l'un d'eux, eh bien, j'étais
Je ne pouvais rien faire à leur sujet
J'étais comme ça et un bon m'a attrapé d'ici et
une des jambes et ils m'ont fait comme ça et maintenant
oui tu sauras ce qui va t'arriver
n'apporte pas d'argent
[Musique]
Rien ne m'est arrivé Dieu merci
Bon
[Musique]
si certains montaient
et on prend ça
jour
ils ne peuvent pas y arriver
valise avec de la marijuana
parce qu'ils vont te tuer et nous ne le ferons pas
ils vous tuent mais si vous n'avez pas de chance ils vous tueront
tuer là-bas comme vous n'êtes pas de quoi
Presque presque généralement, ils prennent pur
les personnes qui ne sont pas du Mexique
mais vous pouvez trouver de bonnes personnes non et
aussi
une autre personne Mais s'ils marchent 10 20 c'est
quand nous sommes arrivés nous nous sommes séparés deux et deux
ou je pars parce qu'on est beaucoup
car ils trouveront beaucoup de danger
devant plus assez dangereux
[Musique]
le problème est là ce n'est pas il n'y a pas
où est il n'y a nulle part
[Musique]
Jackson Nogales
Je suis mexicain mais tu ne connais pas le mien
pays où j'ai passé 25 ans aux États-Unis
Les États-Unis m'ont donné l'occasion
être comme quelqu'un des États-Unis
Ils ont donné l'école, je suis allé au lycée
tout ça
Je suis entré en tant que migrants et je
ils m'ont donné l'opportunité de faire comme eux
malheureusement je n'ai pas su en profiter
J'étais jeune et j'avais une autre mentalité
J'y suis allé avec des amis et ils ont fait quelque chose et j'ai
Ils les ont rattrapés avec des fusils et tout
pour traîner avec eux, j'ai payé dix ans de
prison et la vérité c'est que j'ai souffert
l'humiliation de la faim froide dont j'ai souffert
tout
et depuis que j'ai été emprisonné et que je n'étais pas
sans citoyen ils m'ont pris mes papiers
ils ont déporté ici
J'ai travaillé mais mais je suis toujours
avec la façon dont je suis seul ici parce que mon
la famille est là mon père ma mère ma
frères mes frères sont tous là
[Musique]
tout comme au Honduras c'est compliqué
peu se gagne, ça ne donne que pour rien d'autre
passez maintenant la nourriture quotidienne à
le reste si on a des enfants à
envoyez-le aux vêtements de médecine scolaire
chaussures tout ce qui ne donne plus
donc parfois les gens doivent
mieux émigrer dans un autre pays
où sont-ils mais nous sommes arrivés à un endroit
parce que je vois qu'il y a un train ici
la station
mais il n'y a rien, ne quittez pas le patio est
plus tard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où sommes-nous
nous nous rapprochons
[Musique]
pas seulement
il y a des feux de circulation
non non non ne deviens pas charnel
ne descendez que si un autre train arrive
passe et quel valpe vous pouvez le télécharger
retour
évidemment mec là ils sont si ronds
réservoirs ronds juste derrière
si vous le connaissez prêt
[Musique]
je vais prendre un café
et comment vont-ils faire
tu ne sais pas encore
puisqu'il faut tout écouter
arrive
Voyons bien
Bonjour Sébastien Pérez
Julio m'a invité
Je l'invite pour un café et je viens de France
La France jusqu'ici Alexandre
c'est très important
à l'ouest et passe par le sud, c'est-à-dire
Lève-toi comme ça et à midi c'est comme ça
côté, c'est-à-dire à midi quand le
la chaleur est plus grande avec laquelle vous devez aller
le soleil est de retour ton ombre doit
être de ce côté
Ouais clair de l'ombre le soleil de retour à la
midi si tu dois le traverser
sens de ton ombre à midi
Si tu bouges et que l'ombre frappe ici, non
l'ombre est du même côté
[Musique]
salut salut
non non Non Non
non je ne comprends pas qu'est ce que tu proposes
Qu'est ce que l'on peut faire
il y a des gens avec qui tu peux entrer
le dédouanement est maintenant fortement restreint
maintenant ce qu'ils accusent c'est la mafia
[Musique]
ra
deux mains
Je suis Américain
Oui tout va bien
[Musique]
Mon père nous a amenés en bus nous sommes arrivés à
la frontière nous sommes restés dans l'église
c'est la saison des pluies nous arrivons et il dit
dit la dame de l'église attends
une grande pluie vient et ils le retiennent
les soldats ne seront pas là et il est venu
une eau nous sommes arrivés à un barrage routier et un
soldat ni regard nous sommes arrivés à l'autre
phoque et ils n'étaient pas comme les yeux de
points de contrôle et nous ne sommes pas arrivés à Los Angeles
La Californie ne ressemble à rien et c'est comme ça
J'ai traversé ça facilement j'étais petit
cinq ans cinq ans et demi c'était la la
bon moment
maintenant c'est plus difficile
qu'en pensez-vous qu'en pensez-vous
de cet endroit ils peuvent passer ici ou ils vont
pour voir comment je pense d'abord que
il faut chercher car je ne connais pas
la frontière est comme un rêve, je ne sais pas quoi
Que va-t-il se passer d'ici au premier?
Il dit certaines choses mais parfois il ne le fait pas
se passe comme un alors
passer de mille dollars perdus à mille
pas plus de dollars pour le laisser là tout à l'heure
cinq autres pour les prendre
il y a des modèles dans l'exemple des États-Unis
qui vous contacte
ils te demandent et travaillent
exemple à partir de là, ils vous envoient déjà demander
A titre d'exemple, trois hommes du Chiapas de
Oaxaca parce qu'il y a des gens très difficiles à
travailler
le passage
l'année suivante il vous recontacte si
Vous avez l'air bien, recontactez-vous
Il dit viens ici et amène-moi un tel
nous y travaillons chez iloy ici
près de tutcho arizonte
là ils ont planté beaucoup de pastèques melon ail
oignon
regarde jusqu'où ils vont moyen
alors là dans le pur coin
ramasse les sauts mais ramasse
pur petit coin en ce moment sans appareil photo allons y
aller voir juste ici
et passer sous le poing
ici s'ils passent s'ils passent gratuitement
ici pour ici et ici seront les États
Rejoint
de cet endroit puis le tunnel entre
vient de cette façon que le moment
ce qui tourne
est-ce la ligne de démarcation Ok alors
il y a des passages passage exactement se font
tunnel ces passages vrai pour ça Et
vous ne savez pas quels billets vous avez mais
c'est aussi dangereux pour l'eau claire
une fois que certains migrants ont traversé ici
quand ils arrivaient il commençait à pleuvoir
dans la partie supérieure l'eau tombe alors
que faisaient-ils, ils ne pouvaient pas revenir en arrière
puis nous avons commencé à lui tendre les mains
l'égout et l'aide
Alors les pompiers lui parlent
nous sommes arrivés et peut-être avec une équipe
de la vie nous ouvrons et crevons le
et c'est là que nous avons commencé à les sortir
[Musique]
le seigneur le seigneur
et ici
Ils arrivent là où toutes les eaux du
ville
les eaux usées semblent être
propre mais peu pollué
contaminé Quel produit est ici de tout
et les migrants marchent presque
c'est un gros problème
Combien de kilomètres sont jusqu'à trois
kilomètres environ jusqu'aux États-Unis
États-Unis vers les États-Unis C'est-à-dire si
l'eau arrive et tu es au fond comme ça non plus
vous avez vous n'avez pas de marge Bien qu'il y ait une
sauf si vous êtes près d'un
d'une bouche d'une prise éventuellement
il est possible de sortir d'une autre manière, non plus
vous sortez
d'ailleurs l'eau porte la pierre porte
les décombres portent tout de même les coups que tu as
et cause ta mort ne t'avertit pas de
soudain
et malheureusement les gens qui sont morts
cette année ce n'était pas de Nogales
ils venaient de l'extérieur ils ne connaissaient pas le terrain
[Musique]
ça s'appelle ça ok
parce que récemment tu te souviens
du Honduras et dit qu'il est venu sur le
train déjà ici tu dois aussi dire
ça fait mal s'est endormi dans le train et pas
est descendu ici et ce train est arrivé et est parti
réveillé en Amérique
En dehors de la façon dont vous vous réveillez désagréable
tu t'es reposé
rêve américain
[Musique]
un jour
lentement
[Musique]
On attend ici je ne vais pas vérifier je vais vérifier
vérifie ça
[Musique]
parce qu'ils vont te tuer
tu dois cacher la voiture
Avec un peu de chance
[Musique]
tueurs à gages
et là il vaut mieux passer la nuit non oui oui
Où est la frontière est à 100 mètres
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il avec
un rôti
si tu le fais depuis
[Musique]
drogue
nord-est sud-ouest et quand vous lisez comme
like Si tu lis les paroles like like the
horloge neso C'est si vous ne l'oubliez pas
nord est sud ouest et de ce côté
allongez-vous, c'est-à-dire que depuis l'après-midi vous avez
que quand le soleil est bon bon bon
bien bien bien la montagne qui par
disparaître c'est comme ça l'ombre
OK ça ne change jamais tu dois connaître l'heure
[Musique]
et l'heure l'heure
Non parce que si tu continues tu fais comme ça si tu continues
l'ombre mais un grand
[Musique]
ah bonne chance
Adieu
Merci au revoir
[Musique]